[موسيقى]
اهلا بكم مشاهدينا الى هذه الحلقه الجديده
من مستقبل الطاقه هذه ملفاتنا
ترسيه لمشروع طاقه شمسيه في دبي يكشف مدى
ارتفاع التكاليف بعد كورونا
بلس تنظف دفاترها من البراميل الورقيه وما
الالتزام الذي قدمته روسيا
[موسيقى]
مشاريع الطاقه الشمسيه شهدت في السنوات
السابقه لجائحه كوفيد ارقاما قياسيه
متتاليه في تخفيض التكلفه الى ان وصلت الى
اخر رقم قياسي سجلته السعوديه بتكلفه
1.04 سنت للكي الساعه لمشروع الشعيبه في
ابريل من عام 2021 بطاقه 600 ميجا وات لكن
بعد ذلك حدثت موجه التضخم العالميه وعادت
الاسعار للارتفاع كيف اصبحت الاسعار اليوم
اخر الترسيات تم الاعلان عنها هذا الاسبوع
للمرحله السادسه من مجمع الشيخ محمد بن
راشد ال مكتوم للطاقه الشمسيه في دبي
بطاقه
1800 ميجا وات اقل سعر اتى من شركه مصدر
الاماراتيه بقيمه
1.62 سنت تقريبا للكيلو وات ساعه ما يشكل
ارتفاعا نسبه 60% تقريبا عن الرقم القياسي
المسجل في السعوديه الاخير وهذا ما يتماشى
الى حد ما مع الارتفاع المسجل في تسعير
اخر مشروعين للطاقه الشمسيه في السعوديه
العام الماضي 20 22 فقط لنعرف كيف تطور
قطاع الطاقه الشمسيه في السنوات العشر
الماضيه نستذكر تسعير المراحل السابقه من
مجمع محمد بن راشد للطاقه الشمسيه المرحله
الاولى تمت ترسيتها في يونيو من عام 2012
بقدره 13 ميجا وات لا تتوفر معلومات عن
سعر تكلفه الطاقه فيها لكن المرحله
الثانيه في يونيو من عام 2012 كانت بقدره
200 ميجاوات ووصل سعر شراء الطاقه فيها
الى
5.6 سنت للكيلو وات ساعه
في المرحله الثالثه من المشروع التي تمت
ترسيتها عام 2016 كانت قدره المشروع عند
800 ميجا وات ووصل سعر تكلفه شراء الطاقه
فيها الى اثنين فاصل 99 سنت للكيلو واتس
ساعه في المرحله الرابعه التي تمت ترسيتها
في سبتمبر من عام 2017 بقدره 250 ميجا وات
وصل سعر تكلفه شراء الطاقه فيها الى 2.4
سنت للكيلو وات ساعه اما المرحله الخامسه
فقد تم ترسيتها في نوفمبر من عام 2019
بقدره 900 ميجا وات وسعر التكلفه
1.7 سنت للكيلو وات ساعه تقريبا واخيرا
المرحله السادسه وهي اول مرحله تتم
ترسيتها بعد جائحه كورونا وجاءت تسعير
فيها كما ذكرنا عند واحد فاصل 62 سنت
للكيلو وات ساعه
[موسيقى]
ارتفاع التكاليف الذي اشرنا اليه لم يمنع
من تسجيل مستوى القياس عالمي جديد في قيمه
استثمارات الطاقات المتجدده العام الماضي
الا ان ضيفتنا التاليه جوري سينج نائبه
المدير العام للوكاله الدوليه للطاقات
المتجدده ايرينا تحذر من ان هذا المستوى
من الاستثمار ما زال بعيدا عما هو مطلوب
للوصول الى اهداف اتفاقيه باريس للمناخ
حقيقي
وفي ظل ما يشهد الاقتصاد العالمي من
تقلبات وارتفاع في نسب الفائده وتاثيرها
على عمليه التمويل كل هذه عوامل وتحديات
قد تؤثر على عمليه تحول الطاقه هل برايك
اننا سنحقق مستهدفات عام 2030
في تقريركم الاخير حول النظره المستقبليه
لتحولات الطاقه في العالم ترون ان العالم
بحاجه لاستثمارات بقيمه 44 ترليون دولار
من الان وحتى عام 2030 وذلك لابقاء عمليه
تحول الطاقه على المسار الصحيح حصه
التقنيات من هذه الاستثمارات تصل الى 35
تريليون دولار هل تتوقعين بان تتحقق هذه
المستهدفات
[موسيقى]
اهلا بكم من جديد اجتماع اوبك بلس هذا
الاسبوع استغرق وقتا طويلا ولم يكن
الاتفاق في نهايته سهلا هناك خمسه اسئله
شائعه عن قرار اوبك بلس الذي اتخذ في
الرابع من يونيو اولا كيف نفهم قرار اوبيك
بلس العنوان العريض ان خفضت حصص الانتاج
بمليون و400 الف برميل يوميا اعتبارا من
مطلع 20 24 ولكن هذا التخفيض ليس للانتاج
الفعلي بل للحصص الرسميه لكل دوله وبما ان
هناك العديد من الدول تنتج اقل من حصصها
الرسميه بكثير فهذا يعني انها لن تضطر
لخفض الانتاج فعليا بل
ستنخفض حصصها على الورق لا اكثر وبذلك
تنظف اوبك بلس دفاترها من البراميل
الورقيه ثانيا ما هي الدول التي انخفضت
حصصها اكبر انخفاض طال حصه روسيا بمقدار
برميل يوميا ثم نيجيريا بثلاثمائه وستين
الف برميل يوميا تقريبا ثم انغولا
وماليزيا واذربيجان وغيرها هذه الدول
جميعها تنتج حاليا باقل من حصصها بكثير
اما بسبب العقومات واما بسبب صعوبات تقنيه
في المقابل زادت حصه الامارات بمئتي الف
برميل يوميا بناء على مطالبه قديمه لتصبح
حصتها اكثر تلائما مع قدرتها الانتاجيه
الفعليه ثالثا هل الحصص الجديده نهائيه
ليس تماما فالدول التي انخفضت حصصها ليست
راضيه تماما وبعضها تؤكد ان لديها القدره
على انتاج اكثر مما تنتج حاليا ولذلك تم
الاتفاق على اعاده تقييم انتاج هذه الدول
من ثلاث جهات مستقله قبل نهايه هذا العام
هذا ينطبق على نيجيريا وكونغو مثلا
اما مستوى انتاج روسيا فستتم مراجعته هذا
الشهر مع تقديم البلاد بيانات جديده عن
انتاجها الى جهات مستقله رابعا هل سيكون
هناك تخفيض فعلي للانتاج التخفيض الفعلي
في المدى المنظور سياتي من السعوديه
منفرده وبشكل تطوعي وهذا لثالث مره منذ
الجائحه ولمده شهر واحد قابل للتمديد
اعتبارا من مطلع يوليو وبمقدار مليون
برميل يوميا هذه الخطوه من قبل الرياض
ينظر اليها الخبراء في البنوك الدوليه على
انها تاكيد لقياده المملكه لتحالف اوبك
بلس ولمصداقيه التخفيضات التي يتم اعلانها
خامسا ما موقف الولايات المتحده من قرار
اوبك بلس البيت الابيض كان رافضا بشده
لتخفيضات الانتاج السابقه التي تم الاعلان
عنها في اكتوبر الماضي وحينها اتخذت اداره
بايدن ردود فعل غاضبه لكن اللهجه تغيرت
الى حد بعيد الان بعد ان ثبتت صحه تقييم
اوبك لوضع السوق النفطيه بدليل استمرار
تراجع اسعار النفط رغم التخفيضات في
الانتاج وهذا ما اكد عليه البيت الابيض في
تعليقه على القرار الجديد من
[موسيقى]
على هامش اجتماعي في فيينا خصنا وزير
الطاقه السعوديه الامير عبد العزيز بن
سلمان بمقابله كشف فيها عن طبيعه
المناقشات مع روسيا حول ضروره توفير
الوضوح والشفافيه الى السوق خصوصا وان
موسكو توقفت مؤخرا عن توفير معلومات
للجهات المستقله عن حجم انتاجها كما تحدث
لنا عن الخطوات التاليه لتقييم القدرات
الانتاجيه في الدول الاعضاء هذا العام
ومنتصف العام المقبل لنتابع
احنا عندنا عقده مضاربين يمكن في منحاول
يدفع بهذا الكثير لكن
هي زي اللي مارسناها في عام 21
اعتقد انه كل اجراءاتنا الاخيره حتى في
شهر ابريل تخفيض اللي سوت الدول المشاركه
معنا
لمنفرده سويتك كقرار منفرد لكل دوله هو
قرار تحوطي
واعتقد انه
في ظل الظروف الراهنه كان في حاجه لتخاذ
اجراء اضافي لكن تقديرنا هو انه في كان
بتكون صعوبات على دول لم نتواصل مع احد
لكن لانه حتى الدول القادره على التخفيض
كان لهم تخفيض في ابريل
لسه بادي نتائج المفروض نشوف تقييم
النتائجها في في منتصف يونيو
جميعا توافقنا معهم على تمديد هذه
التخفيضات التوعيه الى نهايه 24 وهذا كميه
مضافه يعني لا ننسى ان مليون وسبع مئه الف
واستمرارها لمده
سنه ونص تقريبا اي واحد يحسبها بكم حجم
الكميات البترول والله ما اعتقد يعني ما
حاول تحسبها لكن سهله الحسب لكن نعتقد انه
انيا نسوق ايضا بحاجه لتطمينات
او اجراء تحوطي يعزز الموثوقيه في انه فيه
من هو قادر بعد مشيه الله انه يعني يتحوط
او يحوط السوق باجراءات اضافيه
تمنع
من انه يتعرض الى تذبذبات سبحان الله بعض
الجهات عشان ما نسميه
يعتقدون حتى بشيء فيه كان في شيء من
التحكم انه يعني السعوديه تنظر للتذبذبات
من جهه واحده فقط شرحتها في المؤتمر
الصاحب من شوي لانه احنا كدوله منتجه
وتاخذ في اعتبارها المدى الطويل
ليس انا لنا مصلحه في تذبذبات قصيره المدى
او متوسط المدى او حتى طويله المدى
هذا امر غير مقبول لبعض المنتفعين ولذلك
نعتقد انه علينا واجب انه نعزز
استقرار واستدامه هذه الاستقرار الاسواق
البتروليه لان هذا معزز لاستقرار صناعه
البترول وبالتالي
وليست فقط
للمملكه ولكن كافه الدول الاوبك بلوس
وايضا الدول المنتجه والصناعه
سمو الامير ذكرت بانه اجراء تحوطي
واحترازي بالنظر الى قرارات اليوم كان
هناك جزء كبير من هذه القرارات فيما يخص
عام 20 24 هل الصوره سلبيه برايكم الى هذه
الدرجه التي دفعتكم لاتخاذ هذه الاجراءات
المحوطيه احنا علينا واجب
نحاول نكون يعني مجددين
لا اريد ان اصفها المبدعين لكن مجددين في
عمليه
اعطاء السوق صوره
مستقبليه طويله
وباليات واضحه
تعبنا من تعطيه دول الحصص ما هي قادره
تنتجها
تعبنا من
ادعاءات انه يعني هذه دوله تقدر تنشر كذا
وتقدر تنشف فقلنا افضل وسيله
لمعالجه الامور هذه اللي يسمونها
بالانجليزي
انه عندك منظور او مدى واضح
تتصرف هذا المدى يتعزز عندما تكون الياتك
منضبطه باجراءات تمكن من تعزيز الموثوقيه
فيها يعني في موضوع الانتاج مراقبه
الانتاج احنا نعتمد على سبع مصادر
الان اللي سويناه جديد هو انه في بعض
الدول
[موسيقى]
رات انه ما
سوف تنتجوا في عام 24 يمكن يكون اعلى شوي
فقلنا لهم على الرحب والسعد في ثلاث جهات
دوليه معروفه
مستقله اذا اقرت انه انتاجكم ممكن يصل الى
هذه المستويات في 24 نعالج رقمكم اللي وفق
عليه اليوم
الاهم الحقيقه هو المعالجه الابديه لموضوع
الحصص
والانتاج المرجعي وهذا
وانتاج المرجع هو ان ايضا بنعتمد على
الجهه الثلاث انه من هنا من بدايه العام
24 الى منتصف 24 كل دول اوبك بلس بما في
ذلك المملكه عشان لا يفسر هذا انه شيء من
اعتداد او شيء من
التعالي انما قلنا لازم ابدا بنفسك هذا
قاعده تبدا بنفسك هو اعتقد هو محقق
العداله ان كل دول اوبك بلس تروح لها
المصادر الجهه المستقله
تعطيها كل المعلومات المطلوبه بحيث انها
تتاكد انه والله الارقامها فيما سوف تنتجه
خمسه وعشرين
هو فنيا سليم وصحيح وممكن ان تصادق عليه
هذا يعفينا من الجدليه الداخليه في في كل
مناشط كل يعني
اجهزه المنظمه او اللجان المنظمه لانه
بتاخذ الطابع
الغير يعني بقضيه المفاوضات اكثر من انها
تقييم فني يراعي
معايير فنيه واضحه هل تعتقد بانه هذه
الاليه والاعتماد على
المراقبين المستقلين
ستنظف الدفاتر من البراميل الورقيه غير
الحقيقيه هذا الاصل هذا الاصل
وليس هناك وسيله متاحه الان الا الاعتماد
على جهاد مستقله
مشهود بالموثوقيه
وهذا الادعى لان لا ندخل انفسنا في انه
يتحول موضوع الى انا عشت الفتاه السابقه
في الثمانينات التسعينات وكانت في نهايه
المطاف الحصص وما ينتج هو عمليه تفوضيه
اكثر من انها عمليه تستند على
الجوانب فنيه دقيقه ولا موضوعيه سؤال
الاخير اسمه الامير تقييمكم لمستويات
الانتاج الروسي والتزامهم خاصه بالحديث
بانه يعني
الامدادات الروسيه وصادراتها الى الصين
الى الاسواق العالميه قد تكون منفصله
حقيقه على ارض الواقع من مستويات الانتاج
يعني بغض النظر عن مستويات الانتاج
الامدادات الروسيه ما زالت قويه بالر
[موسيقى]
كان لنا نقاش مع
روسيا والجانب الروسي في انه عليكم
مسؤوليه في انكم تكون واضحين تكون
وشفافين في اعطاء المعلومات هم اخذوا من
فتره قرار بعدم نشر معلومات اعتقد انه
الان يعرفون انه عدم نشر المعلومات
ادى الى ظهور هذه الظاهره الجديده واتمنى
التشكيك في معلومات ارقامهم وكذا انما
الحقيقه الان وقدام البلاء يعني في
المؤتمر الصحفي ذكرت لاربع جهات من الجهات
اللي هي من السبع الجهات اللي نعتمد عليها
في عمليه تقييم الارقام الشهريه انه
تواصلوا معاهم اعطوهم معلومات اضافيه
ذكرهم بعض الجوانب اللي يعتقدون كان فيها
خلل او خطا
والاضافه الى ذلك
التزموا انه يتواصلوا معهم شهريا للتثبت
فعشان كذا بتلقى في الاتفاق حطينا انه
انتاج فبراير روسيا هو جالس يعاد النظر في
من اربع من الجهات
السبع في ثلاث جهات لظروف الحظر وكذا هي
غير قادره على التواصل مع الجانب الروسي
لكن قلنا اذا كان فيه تعديل لشهر فبراير
من خلال اخذ معدل مره اخرى ارقام الجهه
السبع بافتراض انه ايون من الاربع جهات
رحل تعدل شيء
بيؤخذ فيه وهذا فيه عداله
للجميع وايضا بس احنا في ممارستنا هذه مع
روسيا عززنا مفهوم الشفافيه
فيما يتعلق
بهذا مشاهدينا نصل الى ختام هذه الحلقه
المستقبل الطاقه للمزيد تابعونا دائما على
تويتر تحت وسم هاشتاج مستقبل الطاقه
ويمكنكم الاستماع الى حلقاتنا على العربيه
بودكاست كذلك الى اللقاء
[موسيقى]
لمتابعه المزيد من الاخبار والبرامج
والقصص الانسانيه والوثائقيات والتقارير
الاخباريه لا تنسوا الاشتراك في قناتنا
على يوتيوب الضغط على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل
جرس التنبيهات